welcome to this video playing michael h
international master michael oops
Michael age let's say he does not have a
name in them 90-93 British champion
Michael Hennigan maybe some I'm not very
active international master nowadays I'm
not sure of course not much evidence yep
ok we have them the Benoni from the
sameish to play the number of games
already with this slide let's see what
setup here comes up with the quick quick
age 5 I had something like that recently
him and a blood scam where I obtained a
very nice position with the quick quick
Queen d2 and Bishop age 6 yeah he might
play b5 no but I'm not so scared about
that just like in this other game that I
mentioned the trade of the bishops was
very helpful um wait yeah ok I'm just
I'm just going for that and now flavor
should be too so that my knight can
easily retreat to f1 if he decides to
kick it with age form I really don't
mind this year with b5 cat 91 III
seafoam and this is looking very similar
to the to the game that i recently had
here on the icc
not against the same clan was a
different opponent but it was it versa
I'm looking very very familiar this
looks very familiar this position ok I'm
going here and it's almost a bit spooky
the similarities I wonder about night at
five here is this a possibility already
night f5 and queen age 6 this is just
winning hmm don't see how he can us g7
yeah don't really see how then this is
Sir then this should win
yeah that's just queen age six at Queen
g7 made its no antidote to that is right
in oh yes this is one of those oops
moments where you where you register
that you really don't have a defense at
least I don't see one I mean I'm talking
all this year I developed sequin g7
mater's unstoppable there's no check our
way to to cover it
yeah this was coming a bit out of the
blue I mean I like the position from a
strategic point of view but checkmate it
didn't look like I would be mating in
five moves yeah so this means he needs
to do against something to do something
against it Quincy seven does not does
not help it's really a maiden for year
nine f5 you must probably play for
Knight e5 Knight b6 something along
these lines and now it's interesting
should I castle yeah yeah 95 still the
Sun still is some a normal position I
mean I prefer white is writing quite
nice for me I think white is clearly
better very clearly better actually but
but it's also maybe a matter of taste I
really don't think the Benoni is
especially great if you have the bishop
exchanged and the queenside frozen but
it was a nicer meeting finish alright
thanks for watching